president Trump's longtime personal
attorney is having a very different
courtroom experience right now Michael
Cohen was ordered to appear today for a
hearing over what to do with the
information federal agents seized from
his home in office last week also
they're physically the adult film
actress who says she had no sexual
encounter with them businessman Donald
Trump and in spirit a name familiar to
Fox News viewers who Cohen revealed to
the judge in the courtroom was a third
client correspondent Laura Engel is in
New York tonight with the latest good
evening or good evening Brett you know
many decisions were made on how to
proceed with this case moving forward
which revolve around attorney-client
privilege Michael Cohen left federal
court today after being ordered last
week by judge Kimball wood to show up
and reveal how many clients he has and
who they are
the Cohens attorneys turned over two of
the three names this morning president
Trump GOP fundraiser Eliot Brody and a
third who asked not to be named the
judge told Cohen's attorney they could
not keep it secret and forced their hand
in court to reveal the name Sean Hannity
the Fox News host responded live on his
radio show earlier today Michael never
represented me in any matter
I never retained him in the in the
traditional sense as retaining a lawyer
I never received an invoice from Michael
I never paid legal fees to Michael but I
have occasionally had brief discussions
with him about legal questions about
which I wanted his input and perspective
and the judge denied Cohen's motion for
a temporary restraining order to keep
investigators from going through the C's
documents saying the matter is moot
because the government has agreed not to
access the documents for now instead the
decision was made to have the government
make copies of all physical and
electronic documents that came from the
rate of Cohen's home and office in hotel
room to give Cohen's attorney the
adult-film actress known as stormy
Daniels who Cohen paid $130,000 to in
2016 has reported hush money for her
alleged
relationship with mr. Trump in 2006 made
an appearance in the courtroom as well
she spoke with reporters after today's
proceedings for years mr. Cohen has
acted like he is above the law
he has considered himself an openly
referred to himself as mr. Trump's fixer
he was played by a different set of
rules or should we say no rules at all
he has never thought that the little man
or especially women and even more women
like me mattered that end now and for
his part Michael Cohen did not make a
comment as he left court today the
government will hand over copies of all
of the documents that were seized to
Cohen's attorneys so his legal team can
look through it all and decide just how
much of it is privileged breath we
wrangle outside the courtroom in New
York Laura thank you